When I started goop in 2008,
my calling is something else besides, you know,
making out with Matt Damon on screen.
Coop lab, we are in a science lab here and what we have,
or lots of, as you can see, shiny stainless steel stuff.
And in here we measure force fields.
And in here we manage measure energy fields between individual atoms and between
atoms and molecules. We move atoms and molecules around.
We've done loads of 60 symbols videos and moving out and some molecules around
you. This lab has goes by the incredibly sophisticated,
take off air one or three, nothing more to read into it.
There was no numerology there. It was on my radar.
It's not something I would generally sit down and watch.
But given that this one is all about energy and energy fields and the double
slit experiment has mentioned. And a number of years back,
we did something as you remember, Brady on quantum, Whoa,
I really wanted to take a look and, um, that's what we're going to do now.
We're going to sit down and I'm proud to stand up. And just.
Another day, I think the opportunity that we have with the goofy.
It looks like a lot of fun, very attractive people doing very attractive thing.
Okay.
Okay. The following series is designed to entertain and inform,
not provide medical advice. Okay. Well,
that's a good disclaimer to have up front.
You should always consult your doctor when it comes to your personal health or
before you start any treatment, as both of us know Brady. However,
if you put stuff in the video information on a video,
often the vast majority of times it's ignored.
The entire universe is made of energy.
0.6% of the universe is considered physical matter.
Okay. So that's actually okay. In terms of the 4.6% of matter,
in fact physicist,
I've got a really embarrassing problem in that they don't know what the vast
majority of the universe is made up of in terms of where we are in terms of what
we're doing in terms of what they're doing. Our 4.6% is pretty much everything.
So let's.
The human body as an energy field.
Okay. What type of energy are we talking? Kinetic energy,
electromagnetic energy, acoustic energy, um, potential energy.
What type of energy? This is, this is already beginning to wind me up.
Because the more connected you are energetically, you will feel.
So it's the same old tropes and the same old means.
So that idea of everything being one integrated whole and how we're all
connected, energetically, et cetera.
I believe that 20% is the age of energy.
Okay. Every century is basically the edge of energy.
Energy drives pretty much everything.
What I don't want to do for a change is come across as
absolutely and utterly, well, this is just nonsense. And that the,
the informed scientists ridiculed in everything,
if there's a placebo element of this, if there's a therapeutic element of this,
perhaps you could argue from that perspective that some of this might have some
value, but let's, let's see where it goes.
Okay, this is bomb push.
Okay. We can't let that one go. I had an exorcism.
If we're talking about exorcisms, this pops might not be the most educational,
but let's go. When it got to the titles, when more off.
I work with energy as a body worker and a chiropractor, you have energy.
That's bound up in the muscles and ligaments and spine and fascia and organs
when you're under stress.
So I show up and actually influence how energy is moving.
Okay. So energy is a really important concept in physics and energy.
Very broadly speaking is the ability to do work,
but it comes in so many different forms. And to a certain extent,
what he's saying, the first part of that is right,
in terms of biochemical energy in your body in terms of your muscles is
mechanical energy and biomechanical energy there.
But how has he influenced them that energy? That's, that's the question.
It's possible that some of the problem though,
is just like misappropriation of the word. Like if they're,
if they're talking about something different,
but they're calling it energy and you're getting all wound up, like, is that,
is, that is all the problem possibly tracked back to that.
I think all the problems tracks back to that,
certainly what I've read online about this that's all of the problems is not
tripod. That's a really, really good point. Brady,
let me just pick something up. Can I put this down? Is that okay for a second?
Okay. No work has been done on this particular body.
I've lifted it up against gravity. I've returned it to the same position.
So no network has been done on this particular body. Of course, I've, you know,
my muscles have had to do various things and there's been energy expended there,
but we have to be really,
really careful how we define different terms for a physicist
in a professional context,
work is the dark product of the force and displacement factors are the
integral of the dot product of the force and displacement factors.
That's obviously not what it's, you know,
if I say you've been working nine to five early,
that's obviously not what brings to mind. So yes,
we have to be careful with language,
but the problem is we physicists have to take some of the blame
because we import everyday language.
It's not just the people out there who aren't physicists misinterpreting this.
I would say we are very guilty in propagating quite a lot of quantum world.
And let's see where this goes.
So I show up and actually influence how energy is moving so that your body can
heal faster than your physical being your emotional, being your mind, your soul.
Just go.
I have to stop at that point because this is meant to be what I dislike is the
goop lab. So there's a scientific Shane forgetting about that, disclaimer,
at the start.
And I don't think that disclaimer is really going to impact too heavily on
people. And now we're talking about the soul within a scientific context.
Okay. Not treating a particular condition when I'm working with people,
but I have a hypothesis.
If you just change the frequency of vibration of the body itself and changes the
way the cells.
I do, I have to stop it there. What,
what the hell do we mean by frequency of vibration? What sort of,
I sort of push myself forward, push Brady, you know, does he, what, what,
what do we, what frequency of vibration.
But.
You know, what is this? And again, this is, um, importing just as you said,
Brady, this is importing particular language of physics and misinterpreting,
not in an everyday context. Of course,
we talk about frequency in physics.
So much quantum physics, right at the heart of quantum physics.
We've got a very simple equation,
which is equally here to new or hitch F does a direct relationship
between energy and frequency.
But the problem is that's then coached in terms of where you're on the same
frequency as me and, you know, very, very everyday,
almost one day in language. And when we start to mix these terms,
that's when it gets dangerous just before he started talking about the soul. My,
my concern is that when he's,
he seems to be coaching this as a valid medical process.
You said yourself, you know,
you can come to work and have a talk about frequency,
and then you can go home and talk to your loved ones and use frequency in a
different context. And that's not a problem. So why are you calling him on it?
Because he's catching this in a scientific context,
whether he's doing that deliberately and whether Paltrow was doing it
deliberately, I don't know that stuff, that part of the, you know,
what's out there and Paltrow, I think she believes this stuff, that guy,
in terms of what he's doing, does he really believe he's affecting people?
Maybe he does.
Is he doing this deliberately is using that language deliberately to put that
scientific sheen on or does he just genuinely believe that? I don't know.
It's like magnet therapy, laser therapy, light therapy, vibrational therapy,
and how they're manipulating the energetic field of a person to heal or break up
tissue, et cetera.
I just, the energetic theme. They've never defined it.
Hesitant to show it just because it, it can look strange,
but I think it's time for the world to see
it, to measure the energy field of the body.
Like somewhere between four and six feet off.
No, no, you cannot. No, you cannot. No, you cannot. That is just.
License show that you are giving off warmth.
And infrared radiation. But in terms of influencing notch,
to that extent where the body's doing this,
that's an energy field he claims to be influencing so that he can control
emotional responses to that extent via infrared. But he,
if he'd mentioned infrared at some point, that might be useful,
but what is that energy field?
Is it possible? You just don't know. And he's,
he has found something and he's able to manipulate something that you just don't
understand.
Yeah. So let's say, um, okay, that's his theory. I've got my theory.
Let's say all human emotions are coached in
terms of, um, completely undetectable. Nanoscopic rings of energy.
Let's put it that way. It's made of chlorine something like medical Koreans,
but they exist out there.
And let's say that love let's wind in some good physics. Terminology.
Love is due to the constructive interference of those rings.
And here it is due to the district of influence interference with all things
they've not been detected yet.
And actually the energy scale is such that we just could never detect them,
prove me wrong. Definitively proved me wrong.
But he's got people. He has got people wobbling around. He's got people saying,
I feel better. Yeah.
So we need empirical evidence because the placebo effect is exceptionally
strong. We do trails of drugs. What we build in the placebo effect.
This is a combination of placebo effect. Culture.
Personality is a fairly attractive and charismatic guy, I would say. Um,
and he's clearly very eloquent and he's clearly,
um, got people hanging off. His,
every word does a huge number of confounding variables here.
The body doesn't end right here at this kid and the body is multi-dimensional.
There are layers to it.
Multi-dimension in what sense, honestly, that's a word that's.
And I'm interacting with those layers.
So when I'm moving my hands in the air and I'm snapping my fingers and I'm
making sounds with my hands, I'm putting energy into the field,
around some of these body and I'm changing their energy system just by the way I
interact with it.
The way we interact with someone without even touching them at the subatomic
level, changes them so much.
No, I've got to stop now. And he is definitely getting it.
Right? So, so he said,
he's influencing the person at the soap atomic level by clicking his
fingers. If we could influence motto at the sober atomic level,
by clicking our fingers, we wouldn't have to spend billions on CERN.
We wouldn't have to, and we wouldn't need this bloody thing.
Not that this is just nonsense. This really is just nonsense. And you know,
the argument will be made well, science doesn't know everything.
So how do you know? Sure. Science doesn't know everything.
If science knew everything I'd be out of a job,
Brady would be out of a job because everything would be out there,
but science knows some things.
And the way that science works is that we have to have empirical measurements
and we have to have evidence if we don't have evidence and you know,
physicists are pretty bad.
I am no fan of the multi-verse because what ex what empirical evidence have we
got for the multi-verse hypothesis? Zilch is what this guy is doing.
You know,
aligned with that to a certain extent in that he's proposing something with no
one periodical evidence. It is.
So I will stress that we really don't want to come across as physicist on his
high horse, you know, spouts off by new age.
Woostoff the way I'm doing now.
But we physicists do have to take some of the blame.
Phil science works by collecting evidence and having a hypothesis and working
through these different procedures, but that that's not how nature works.
So for example, I don't know how my car works,
but I know when I press the accelerator, it drives.
Is it possible that you don't know?
And even he doesn't know how the human body energy field works,
but he's just stumbled across the fact that when he clicks his fingers at a
certain location, it cures people,
just like I know when I press the accelerator, the car works. I don't know why,
but I know it does.
Is this repeatable. If we do this under, um,
controlled experimental conditions, can he do this?
So for one thing, I would love to say, he's talking his way through.
You can hit the hands are clicking around.
What if we were to put a blindfold on people and whatever we put our headphones
on and do it in an entirely darkened room. He says, it works up to six,
six feet away. I think somewhere between three and six feet away,
completely isolate the person.
Don't give them any hints as to where his hands are or what he's doing.
And let's then see what the emotions are.
Maybe it works because it's him, maybe,
maybe his quantum energy field chakra is what makes it
work. And therefore it's not repeatable by you because you haven't,
you're not here.
Can use him.
The question is let's cut out external stimuli and see if this still works.
Let's see if they're doing all this motion or that is solely due to
suggestion and the placebo. And we know how strong the placebo effect.
There's been some amazing research done in the realm of quantum physics to
support this one foundational study is called the double slit experiment
proved apparently without a shadow of a doubt that our consciousness actually
shifts or altars in some way, shape or form physical reality.
Right? Does. Sorry, but that is.
The idea that you might have to bleep a lot, but really,
truly utterly complete.
The man is talking out of his nether regions that has not been empirically
proved beyond a shadow of a doubt. So irritating the infrastructure tingly.
Some scientists have actually have claimed this.
Some very important businesses include Ning Heisenberg himself,
but we don't have that evidence. We do not. That evidence is not there.
There are probably at last count,
something like 25 different theories of quantum mechanics and there's no or
interpretations of quantum mechanics.
And there's no empirical evidence that definitively says this one is important
over this one is information important. Yes,
it seems to be is knowing the trajectories of particles
and how that plays into a norm, the history of particles and indeed,
even future particles. Does all of that plant or quantum mechanics? Yes.
Do we understand the math? Yes.
Can we do incredibly sophisticated calculations and predict what happens in the
real world? Yes. Do we understand it? No.
And physicist re what really winds me up is when physicist presents
something as sort of a theater complex, and this happens all the time,
particularly know things like many worlds,
that's one interpretation of quantum mechanics. Multi-verse,
that's one interpretation of physics in terms of empirical evidence for either
none doesn't mean we can't talk about it.
Does it absolutely doesn't mean we can't talk about it. And the thing is,
I'm going to cut this guy, some Slack here for a change,
because when you have physicists of the caliber of Heisenberg,
indeed Martin Reese,
Mirman those type of people basically saying without any
real qualification, yes. Consciousness is so important for quantum mechanics.
Can you blame this guy?
Or can you blame people like Deepak Chopra and the unalike for taking this on
board? And, you know, as I say,
we physicists really are sort of propagating our own little Quanta of womb.
Every time we get up and we don't make it really, really clear, actually,
we don't fully understand this.
Degenerate the way you're moving through the spine to try to manipulate the flow
of information between the brain nervous system and muscles. This.
I know I'm interrupting a lot, but this suspicious, really the crux of this,
how is he doing that really? How is he doing that? And you know, if we were to.
Do you belong, walk in here and I don't know how you're doing stuff,
but I believe you're doing it. You tell me, you tell me that in that machine,
you've manipulated atoms and you've moved them.
And you show me a picture on a screen, but I don't know you did it.
You could sit here and you could watch every single step of that process,
in fact.
But he's doing that. He's letting us watch his process.
So what what's not,
but I can show you exactly from the point of here's how we measure the current.
This is the instrument we use to measure the current.
The way I do it is I move my hand here and I feel an energy here. And I,
and I click my fingers.
Energy, and how was the influence on it? But you know, you do know,
cause I've bored. You've sensed that.
It's happening, but I don't know that it's happening, but I can.
Show you that current, I can show you that measurement. We can,
we can get a meter and we can see that current okay.
Balanced, but I'm watching him move his hand.
And then I'm seeing the people on the bed go and move around and have their
little exorcism and like,
and there were multiple explanations for it.
But you can't say that he hasn't shown it.
If I go I'm influenced in my quantum fields.
Ready? Do you believe me?
No, I personally don't.
So what's the difference between me and him apart from he's much more attractive
as much more hair.
I think everybody at Duke knows me to be a bit of a skeptic skeptic.
A lot of people's emotional energy gets bound up the tip of the tailbone.
Okay. That's a really great example. No, that,
there's a really what we were talking about earlier, Brady,
in terms of energy being used in this sense of positive and negative emotional
energy as compared to a physical entity,
that that's a real issue here in terms of confusing those two contexts,
very different contexts in terms of semantics. It's not,
it's not in this context where he's,
he's arguing that he's to make people feel better by changing their energy
fields.
So there's a question of the physical energy field being confused for the
emotional energy. But.
If you said, Oh, we've just got a new member in our research group.
And like she's giving off really good energy.
I think she's going to be really good. I wouldn't sit there and go, Oh,
do you mean kinetic energy or electric?
No, neither would we all stereotypes of folk physicists to one side,
but we wouldn't be claiming to be able to stand beside or three feet away and
influence our energy and soul change our state of mind,
which is what he's claiming.
This is where a controlled study whereby she's got some headphones on and she's
listening to them some nice relaxing music, unexplained folder,
and it's completely in the dark.
I would like to see if the reactions would be the same.
But feel maybe that external stimuli,
the handsome man with the nice hair and the nice voice maybe that is
contributing to this cocktail of physical things that are
happening that make it work.
Maybe it's the only thing. And how would we do that? I would,
we isolate one effect from the other.
We do a controlled study where you try to control the variables in the
environment.
There was that stress.
I don't trust anyone that wears all black outfit like that.
Yeah. I'll give him that.
I will give him that the man has got a key sense of style and
sartorial elegance. It's gotta be said. And look at that.
How do you feel about this being made and put out there?
That's a really good question. Really good question. Um,
am I worried about it?
I am worried about it in terms of disseminating that type of it's
nonsense. You know, it really is no scientific basis.
They've got the disclaimer or fluent front for all of 10 seconds. You know,
you've got that simple writing on a black background or whatever against
incredibly attractive people. You know, being, you know,
saying my life has been radically changed, you know, one is or where the other,
if it's a therapy, if that's all it is,
is a therapy and it's a placebo and people are coming out of those sessions.
And if you offend someone about an I, I'm not gonna argue with that. You know,
religion plays that role in many people's lives as well.
My key concern is particularly when this is pushed as a medical
procedure, when it will treat cancer or treat other forms of disease.
That's when I got really, really scared.
And actually we need to regulate this time. Should this be on Netflix?
This should, it comes back to the question of balance. I would say,
um, they can present the aspects of this,
but the really should be a counterbalance in this. They pretty got pretty,
what's got free ran in terms of what they present the should be physicists.
The should be doctors. There should be chemists.
There should be whatever right across the board saying, no, this is wrong.
This doesn't work. Explain this, explain this just as we're doing now,
we shouldn't have to rely on 60 symbols to, to, you know,
take this to pieces that should happen in the process itself. But of course,
you know, is that going to is a fully balanced documentary like that,
going to attract any like anything like the attention this is attracted. No,
of course now where is the evidence that what he's doing works,
there's no evidence at all.
We've seen some people moving around the very first step in that as a controlled
experiment where you caught out his visual and his audible cues and
do a perfectly controlled experiment and then see how those people behave.
And if honestly,
if they do that experiment and where people have headphones on and blindfolds on
in a darkened room and they move and they have no cue at all as to where his
hands are and his entrance, I would be over the moon. Oh my,
that would like revolution attack. I will get a Nobel prize.
Let's put it this way. I'm not going to bet the bloody house it's on it.
That that's going to happen maybe in the sixties.
And what it does is it connects new air J ideas,
sort of Eastern mysticism with quantum mechanics and quantum physics.
The idea that, you know,
quantum physics means that there's an interconnectedness to all things and
Withers and universal spirit, et cetera, all these type of things.